ciao mi chiamo Olivia Lan e sono una ricercatrice e un'educatrice presso IBM Quantum questo video segna il lancio di una
nuovissima serie sul canale YouTube di Qiskit e sulla nostra piattaforma di apprendimento chiamata Quantum Computing in
pratica in breve in questa serie ti mostrerò come usare un computer quantistico che esiste proprio ora al suo
pieno potenziale ci sono già miliardi di video su internet sui computer quantistici e sul loro futuro potenziale o sui concetti teorici
alla base del calcolo quantistico che sono altrettanto importanti vedi capire l'informazione e il calcolo quantistico
ospitato da John Watrous per esempio ma in questo corso assumeremo che chi impara sa già qualcosa di più
di quanto abbiamo fatto in passato e andremo molto lontano tecnicamente parlando e questo perché nell'ultimo anno e al
momento di questa registrazione siamo nel 2024 abbiamo visto uno spostamento una transizione di fase se vuoi verso una nuova era del
calcolo i computer quantistici si stanno finalmente avvicinando al punto in cui possono essere utili anche se sperimentare con
circuit su piccola scala e computer quantistici era necessario per educare la nostra comunità su come utilizzare queste macchine nessuno stava eseguendo esperimenti
che non potessero essere eseguiti anche su normali vecchi computer classici ma ad oggi siamo entrati in un'era di
utilità quantistica e cos'è l'utilità potresti chiederti è diversa dal Vantaggio Quantistico che può essere inteso al
punto in cui i computer quantistici superano i computer classici in un compito significativo invece l'utilità significa
che possono iniziare a competere l'uno con l'altro e questo è il passo successivo naturale nell'evoluzione
tecnologica IBM ha pubblicato un articolo che ha mostrato per la prima volta l'anno scorso che un computer quantistico poteva essere usato per
simulare un modello fisico e competere con le tecniche di simulazione classica all'avanguardia ha persino superato i
tentativi di forza bruta e ha permesso ai ricercatori di avere una nuova strada che possono usare per la ricerca quindi perché sta succedendo tutto questo
ora beh negli ultimi mesi IBM ha reso ampiamente disponibili processori quantistici di oltre 100 qubit se sei già
un utente potresti aver notato che abbiamo rimosso molti dei nostri processori più piccoli per fare spazio a questi chip più grandi e abbiamo sentito che era davvero
importante farlo perché alcuni numeri di qubit possono ancora essere simulati classicamente senza problemi quindi non c'è
un vero vantaggio che si può ottenere usando questi chip tuttavia con 100 qubit questo non è più il caso non possono
essere simulati classicamente è anche importante notare che ci sono queste cose chiamate simulatori che
sono essenzialmente programmi per computer e possono imitare alcuni comportamenti dei sistemi quantistici incluso il rumore tuttavia per favore
non perdere di vista il fatto che ho detto imitare i simulatori non sono computer quantistici non possono produrre i risultati che
i computer quantistici possono a questa scala ma sono ancora una parte importante del nostro flusso di lavoro di test quindi quella era una risposta molto
lunga alla domanda in cima a questa diapositiva cos'è il calcolo quantistico pratico in questo corso ti insegnerò i realistici
potenziali casi d'uso per il quantistico e le migliori pratiche per eseguire ed effettuare esperimenti su questi processori di scala più grande
oggi quindi a chi è rivolto questo corso iniziamo facendo un po' di allineamento
all'inizio questo corso è per tutti coloro che mirano a sviluppare nuove applicazioni per computer quantistici vogliono
sapere come scalare il loro lavoro attuale o imparare come usare il quantistico nei loro flussi di lavoro esistenti ho precedentemente
detto che questo corso sarà molto pratico e non discuteremo gli aspetti teorici quasi quanto ci aspettiamo che tu
venga con una comprensione di base di cosa sia il calcolo quantistico ma se non sei ancora arrivato lì non preoccuparti guarda semplicemente
i primi episodi del corso di John Watrous e sarai pronto vogliamo anche assicurarci che le persone che guardano sappiano
che questo non è solo un corso per fisici o anche informatici queste due materie hanno davvero
monopolizzato il Calcolo Quantistico nell'ultimo decennio o giù di lì vogliamo assicurarci che altri che lavorano con big data o
simulazioni come ingegneri chimici e scienziati dei materiali sappiano che questo corso è anche per loro in sintesi questo
corso è rivolto a un pubblico ampio e speriamo che ti unisca a noi per tutta la sua durata dopo aver completato questo corso
sarai in grado di capire come creare ed eseguire un lavoro di scala utilitaria attraverso Qiskit Runtime incluso l'intero flusso di lavoro
sarai in grado di capire i principali tipi di mitigazione degli errori e anche capire le probabili aree di applicazione a breve termine sarai anche in grado di
eseguire tutti questi algoritmi in Qiskit e infine ci aspettiamo che tu sia in grado di capire il rumore e come gestirlo
quindi iniziamo il Calcolo Quantistico è un'eccitante nuova tecnologia in una fase iniziale di sviluppo ma è solo
un capitolo nella storia del calcolo che risale a migliaia di anni fa penso che sia importante capire questo
contesto perché rende ciò che stiamo cercando di fare qui un po' più intuitivo prevedibile e meno
fantascientifico sin dai tempi antichi noi come esseri umani abbiamo avuto bisogno di eseguire calcoli o
in altre parole elaborare informazioni secondo certe regole e vincoli per consentire la
comunicazione la costruzione il commercio la scienza e tutti gli altri aspetti della nostra vita ci siamo rivolti al mondo fisico
per assistenza e attraverso scoperte ingegnose abbiamo costruito dispositivi per aiutarci a calcolare tanto tempo fa i dispositivi erano
fatti di legno osso corde annodate e memorizzavano informazioni e facilitavano calcoli in modo molto diverso da come lo facciamo
oggi i dispositivi meccanici costruiti da leve ingranaggi e altri macchinari sono avanzati dai primi orologi astronomici ai
calcolatori fino a sofisticati dispositivi di calcolo come gli analizzatori differenziali che risolvevano equazioni usando ruote e
dischi rotanti anche la tecnologia della scrittura ha svolto un ruolo importante nella storia permettendo alle persone di eseguire
calcoli che altrimenti non sarebbero stati in grado di fare quando pensiamo ai computer oggi tendiamo a pensare ai
computer digitali elettronici ma questa è in realtà una tecnologia abbastanza recente i computer digitali elettronici
furono costruiti per la prima volta negli anni '40 lo strumento più antico conosciuto per il calcolo è in realtà l'abaco sumero
che gli esperti pensano fosse stato inventato a Babilonia nel 2700-2300 a.C. è davvero
molto tempo fa ma abbiamo capito sempre di più il mondo naturale da Archimede a Euclide a
Einstein il nostro bisogno di più risorse computazionali è esploso oggi abbiamo supercomputer che sono
fondamentalmente molti computer molto potenti collegati in parallelo sono uno dei migliori strumenti che l'umanità ha per
risolvere problemi difficili ma ci sono ancora molti problemi che anche questi giganteschi computer non saranno mai in grado di
risolvere di più su questo più avanti quindi abbiamo stabilito che gli esseri umani hanno usato la fisica e la natura per aiutarci a calcolare
per migliaia di anni e per aiutarci nella nostra ricerca infinita di calcolare cose sempre più grandi potresti già
conoscere la Legge di Moore in realtà non è una legge quanto piuttosto un'osservazione la parte della legge è un po'
ironica secondo me il numero massimo di transistor in un circuito integrato fondamentalmente un chip per computer
raddoppia ogni 2 anni circa negli ultimi 5 decenni o giù di lì non solo lo abbiamo osservato ma ne abbiamo fatto grande uso
con più transistor possiamo eseguire calcoli più velocemente questo è essenzialmente ciò che è responsabile del fatto che i
computer diventano sempre più potenti e più piccoli nel tempo tuttavia ci sono alcune cattive notizie la legge di Moore sta morendo
gli esperti non sono d'accordo su quando la legge di Moore arriverà alla sua fine inevitabile ma alcuni dicono che è già accaduto anche se potremmo non
essere esattamente sicuri di quando raggiungeremo il nostro limite sappiamo che è alla fine inevitabile perché alcune parti dei transistor
non possono essere rese fisicamente più piccole non puoi fare un transistor più piccolo di un atomo per esempio questo
è ovviamente completamente non fisico sembra assurdo ma questi sono i limiti con cui stiamo effettivamente lavorando quindi cosa
faremo semplicemente arrenderci e dire hey è il meglio che possiamo fare no gli esseri umani non hanno mai fatto questo fortunatamente la
meccanica quantistica è entrata nella conversazione la meccanica quantistica fu scoperta negli anni '20 e da allora il mondo non è
letteralmente mai stato lo stesso e potremmo passare ore a parlare delle scoperte rivoluzionarie che furono
fatte ma non è davvero il focus di questo corso invece voglio chiarire che sappiamo che la
meccanica quantistica e il calcolo sono già compatibili tra loro le scoperte e le comprensioni della natura
che abbiamo appreso dalla meccanica quantistica hanno in parte reso possibili i nostri moderni computer senza la
meccanica quantistica non capiremmo o probabilmente non avremmo nemmeno potuto inventare l'hard disk a stato solido per
esempio il calcolo quantistico è semplicemente il passo naturale successivo in questa evoluzione
ma il calcolo non esiste solo nel vuoto l'informazione richiede un mezzo
elaborare informazioni sfrutta il mondo fisico e lo influenza anche questo pone limitazioni su ciò che è fisicamente possibile ma capire la natura e i limiti fisici è in realtà l'obiettivo della fisica come
disciplina quindi in un certo senso la fisica e il calcolo sono sempre stati intrecciati Ralph Landauer un informatico e un
ricercatore IBM ha riconosciuto decenni fa che l'informazione è fisica in altre parole l'informazione non è un'
entità astratta ma esiste solo attraverso la rappresentazione fisica il principio di Landauer stabilisce una connessione
tra informazione e le leggi della termodinamica ma in realtà ci sono molte connessioni tra fisica e
calcolo la fisica classica era tutto ciò che eravamo in grado di esplorare fino a poco tempo fa ma con la scoperta della
meccanica quantistica siamo ora sull'orlo di essere in grado di creare un modo completamente nuovo di calcolare e questo è ottimo perché
i computer classici possono solo approssimare ciò che accade effettivamente in natura e in alcuni casi tale approssimazione è molto
limitata questo perché è davvero molto difficile far sì che macchine che seguono le leggi della fisica classica
approssimino le leggi della fisica quantistica e la natura non è classica è quantistica un'analogia che potrebbe aiutarti a
capire è un tunnel del vento la fluidodinamica è notoriamente difficile da simulare e prevedere matematicamente
anche qualcosa di banale come un'auto che guida attraverso il vento i produttori di auto hanno scoperto che era in realtà
troppo costoso e poco pratico cercare di simulare questa interazione fisica quando progettavano le auto invece quello che
hanno finito per fare è creare un vero tunnel che soffia vento attraverso di esso e semplicemente guidare un'auto nel tunnel
e vedere come si comporta questo è analogo a quello che intendo quando dico che i computer classici approssimano solo
povaramente la natura e a volte è troppo costoso anche solo tentare di farli farlo invece di simulare il vento
i ricercatori lo ricreano semplicemente analogamente i computer quantistici non devono approssimare le leggi della natura a livello
molecolare perché seguono quelle leggi intrinsecamente non devono simulare nulla lo emulano e
le stesse difficoltà sorgono quando simuliamo batterie o reazioni chimiche il che ci porta alla nostra prossima
sezione il Calcolo Quantistico a cosa serve quindi
perché vorremmo anche pensare di combinare la meccanica quantistica e il calcolo beh ci sono già molti
problemi che sono troppo difficili troppo costosi computazionalmente anche per i nostri supercomputer all'avanguardia da risolvere
forse questi sono problemi su cui solo i ricercatori sono molto concentrati ma i loro impatti potrebbero toccare tutte le parti del
globo questi problemi su cui i computer classici si bloccano sono cose su cui noi come Società ci stiamo basando sempre di più
sulla tecnologia e che ci interessano davvero come l'efficienza delle batterie la modellazione finanziaria e l'
ottimizzazione e persino come costruire aerei migliori quindi perché ricorrere ai computer quantistici beh abbiamo ottime ragioni
per pensare che ci sia molto potenziale qui e possiamo aprire porte a nuovi calcoli che sono attualmente fuori portata anche per i
più potenti supercomputer in teoria alcuni algoritmi quantistici forniscono vantaggi rispetto ai
migliori algoritmi classici possibili per alcune applicazioni per altre applicazioni c'è crescente evidenza che anche
con un po' di rumore e imperfezioni i computer quantistici possono ancora essere usati come uno strumento per competere con la forza bruta
classica fondamentalmente è uno strumento completamente nuovo e vogliamo scoprire anche cose ancora più interessanti che possiamo fare con esso ma possiamo
anche guardare all'idea originale di Feynman per essi che è usarli per capire la fisica e la natura di per sé
dopotutto ti ho già detto che la natura è quantistica non classica e questo campo è incredibilmente ricco affascinante e
interdisciplinare unisce fisica informatica elaborazione dell'informazione e naturalmente i domini specifici delle aree di applicazione che
potrebbero interessarci tuttavia a differenza dei computer classici non tutti hanno un computer quantistico nella tasca
posteriore fino a poco tempo fa se volevi sperimentare con un computer quantistico dovevi costruirlo e mantenerlo
da solo di solito in un triste laboratorio interrato in un'università o struttura di ricerca e fidati che lo saprei bene non è più
così tuttavia nel 2016 IBM ha messo il primo processore quantistico sul cloud aveva solo cinque qubit all'epoca e
tassi di errore abbastanza elevati ma erano solo 8 anni fa e guarda quanto siamo arrivati lontano quindi dove siamo oggi
ci sono molti parallelismi da tracciare con i primissimi giorni del computer moderno come ho detto questa è una sfida molto
difficile ed è stato solo negli ultimi 8 anni che i computer quantistici sono diventati ampiamente disponibili a parte coloro
che lavorano in un laboratorio o struttura all'avanguardia ma in quegli ultimi otto anni abbiamo fatto progressi su ogni
fronte i processori sono di ordini di grandezza più grandi in termini di numero di qubit i gate sono notevolmente migliorati e abbiamo introdotto metodi
su ogni fronte i processori sono ordini di grandezza più grandi in termini di numero di qubit i gate sono notevolmente migliorati e abbiamo introdotto metodi
per ridurre o mitigare gli errori intrinseci ai sistemi quantistici anche mentre spingiamo avanti per creare computer quantistici
tolleranti ai guasti ora tu e chiunque altro potete usare uno di questi numerosi processori IBM Quantum che sono
ospitati sul cloud quasi tutti i quali sono i sistemi più nuovi, recenti e migliori con oltre 100
qubit ma non è solo la dimensione dei processori che è importante questa è solo una metrica che ci interessa e
ha senso giusto se abbiamo più qubit è ovviamente meglio a condizione che aumentare il numero di qubit
non degradi le prestazioni tuttavia questo non è sempre il caso abbiamo bisogno di più qubit di buona qualità che non interferiscano
tra loro attraverso il crosstalk quando non vogliamo che lo facciano come i qubit sono connessi tra loro è anche qualcosa importante da tenere a mente nei
circuit superconduttori è una sfida capire come collegare fisicamente al meglio i qubit un'altra metrica enormemente importante
è la fedeltà del gate a due qubit i gate che girano su singoli qubit non sono così soggetti a errori i gate a due qubit sono la zona di
maggiore preoccupazione e di solito una delle metriche di riferimento che cerchiamo per vedere come le prestazioni migliorano nel
tempo i gate a due qubit sono cruciali da ottenere correttamente perché sono responsabili della creazione di entanglement tra i qubit
che è uno dei fenomeni fisici che conferisce ai computer quantistici il loro potere infine cerchiamo velocità ed efficienza
dobbiamo assicurarci che il tempo trascorso a eseguire un programma sul chip quantistico sia eseguito nel modo più rapido ed efficiente
possibile ci riferiamo a queste tre metriche insieme come scala qualità e
velocità tutte sono vitali per migliorare le prestazioni ora voglio mostrarti alcuni grafici rapidi per supportare ciò che ho detto
su come la tecnologia stessa si stia davvero evolvendo abbastanza rapidamente il numero di qubit in sé è il più facile da
capire penso e IBM ha pubblicato una tabella di marcia di dove speriamo di essere nei prossimi anni in termini di numero di qubit
e dimensione del processore per il 2024 quando stiamo girando questo video siamo perfettamente in linea con il nostro processore Heron e Condor poi
qualità questo grafico mostra il tasso medio di errore del gate di entanglement per i processori IBM Quantum nel tempo tieni a mente
che questa è una scala logaritmica quindi mentre il progresso sembra vagamente lineare è in realtà molto più rapido di così
infine abbiamo la velocità questo grafico mostra il progresso di una metrica che chiamiamo CLOPS che sta per circuit layer
operations per second crucialmente CLOPS racchiude sia il tempo necessario per eseguire circuit sia il calcolo classico real e
near-time fondamentalmente CLOPS è una misura di quanto velocemente i nostri processori possono eseguire circuit specifici in
serie agendo come una misura della velocità olistica del sistema e incorporando il calcolo quantistico e classico
in questo momento al momento della registrazione IBM è il solo fornitore quantistico cloud che sta fornendo accesso a
macchine con oltre 100 qubit come ho detto qualche diapositiva fa 100 qubit o lì intorno è dove la simulazione classica
inizia a fallire completamente quindi i lavori su larga scala eseguiti su queste macchine spesso non hanno un equivalente classico non è
possibile c'è qualche sfumatura e qualche trucco che puoi usare per simulare alcune parti di un circuit e poi altre
parti separatamente ma in generale sappiamo che intorno a questo numero è dove i computer quantistici possono iniziare a fare cose che i computer classici semplicemente non possono quindi
IBM ha deciso che dare accesso a questi dispositivi più grandi era super importante per la comunità più ampia perché qualsiasi cosa
fatta su dispositivi più piccoli è simulabile classicamente e quindi non può portare al Vantaggio Quantistico i dispositivi da 100 qubit
che abbiamo ora sono ancora difettosi e ancora rumorosi quindi dobbiamo essere intelligenti su come eseguiamo lavori e
circuit su di essi scrivere il nostro circuit e premere shift invio probabilmente non porterà a niente
di spettacolare ma di nuovo ci sono trucchi e pratiche migliori che possiamo implementare e seguire per spremere ancora
più prestazioni da questi dispositivi il che porterà sperabilmente al Vantaggio Quantistico prima anche mentre continuiamo
a lavorare e costruire le nostre macchine tolleranti ai guasti anche questo grafico mostra il costo di simulazione
o la quantità di tempo necessaria per risolvere un problema sui computer classici e sui computer quantistici dotati di mitigazione degli errori
e correzione degli errori quindi la linea del calcolo classico scala esponenzialmente man mano che la complessità del circuit
cresce per circuit semplici qui in basso non importa ma è ovviamente negativo man mano che la complessità cresce perché questo
rende il costo di simulazione molto costoso molto rapidamente la mitigazione degli errori scala meglio quindi quando la complessità del
circuit cresce è qui che vogliamo essere siamo attualmente qui con metodi classici e quantistici più o meno alla
pari per alcune applicazioni e la correzione degli errori potrebbe essere la più preferibile e scala davvero
bene non ci siamo ancora nel frattempo continueremo a concentrarci sulla mitigazione degli errori e ad arrivare in questa
area di utilità quantistica il prima possibile e facendo uso di diversi schemi di mitigazione degli errori che
impareremo in questa serie miriamo a trovare aree di applicazione che possano fare uso dell'utilità quantistica molto presto e questo è
davvero il cuore di questo corso abbiamo queste macchine pensiamo che siano capaci di fare ricerche davvero interessanti
quindi come le usiamo in quest'ultima sezione dell'episodio discutiamo brevemente le aree di applicazione per il
Calcolo Quantistico pratico ci sono tre rami principali che pensiamo di essere più entusiasti di esplorare e trovare strade per l'utilità
quantistica il primo è simulare la natura questo riguarda la simulazione di interazioni molecolari o atomiche ed è
davvero importante per le aree della scienza dei materiali e della chimica e per le ragioni che abbiamo discusso prima pensiamo che i computer
quantistici saranno molto meglio in questo rispetto alle loro controparti classiche poi c'è la ricerca e
l'ottimizzazione il principale algoritmo di interesse qui si chiama QAOA un algoritmo ibrido classico-quantistico QAOA usa un
computer classico per allenare e trovare parametri ottimali per un circuit quantistico e speriamo di essere in grado di farlo
molto più efficientemente di quanto potrebbe fare uno dei due computer da soli infine abbiamo la matematica e l'elaborazione di dati strutturati i computer
quantistici sono molto bravi a trovare struttura in dati disordinati dove tu o io o un tipico computer potremmo non vedere
nulla l'apprendimento automatico quantistico è promettente in quest'area e miriamo a usarlo per compiti come l'estrazione di
caratteristiche e il riconoscimento di pattern è davvero un momento molto emozionante per quelli di noi che lavorano nel
campo del calcolo quantistico per la prima volta nella storia possiamo iniziare ad esplorare una regione del calcolo che va oltre il
calcolo classico quelli di voi che guardano questo potrebbero possibilmente giocare un ruolo simile ai primi pionieri del
calcolo e loro non avevano alcuna concezione di ciò che sarebbe seguito T J Watson di IBM ha persino detto famosamente che pensava ci fosse
un mercato per solo due o tre computer in totale e wow quanto si sbagliava noi
siamo tutti quei primi pionieri del calcolo ma in questo nuovo campo del calcolo quantistico e il quantistico viene spesso
contrapposto al calcolo classico come qualcosa di decisamente diverso da esso e spesso in competizione con esso ma il mio
obiettivo per questa lezione introduttiva era di convincerti che da un punto di vista a volo d'aquila possiamo vedere il calcolo
quantistico semplicemente come il prossimo capitolo in una lunga storia del calcolo è nella nostra natura come esseri umani cercare nuovi modi di
calcolare e di sfruttare il potere del mondo naturale e capire cosa farne e lo facciamo da
secoli il calcolo quantistico ci offre un nuovo strumento in questo sforzo e sta a noi scoprire come possiamo sfruttare
il potere che ci offre nella prossima lezione della serie parleremo un po' di più dei sistemi a 100 qubit
e daremo una panoramica di Qiskit il nostro SDK software quantistico e di come interagire al meglio con queste macchine in questo momento grazie per
aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta